in the Kickstarter video you have a
image of a man fighting off another man
on a boat or there's a fight that takes
place so we see that it's a turbulent
environment some of the filming that
you've been exposed to are you worried
about your own personal safety I'm
worried about Christopher's safety all
the time you know they're not there you
know it's it's filming in Cambodia in
particular I just want to all just speak
for that because it's probably different
in different countries but you kind of
get a pass a bit for being a westerner
and you have a certain degree of
protection that locals don't have and so
a lot of journalists who are Cambodian
and a lot of environmental steward
Cambodian are either imprisoned or
sometimes disappeared or there are some
prominent cases of very public killings
that of course never really get solved
or get tied to anybody so it's a lot
more dangerous for them than it is for
people like us going in however when
you're out on the open oceans a lot of
things can accidentally happen and
actually we you know in the course of
making this film learned about local
Cambodian champ fisherman who was killed
by Vietnamese fishermen and of course
that also nobody was held responsible
for that and you know so there is a
certain amount of danger for sure and
particularly on these boats are really
small and you know it's it's there's not
a lot of places to run and hide you know
you can't just run away it's like you're
you're stuck there so there was a few
moments which isn't in the Kickstarter
video and might not even be in the film
but where we were out on patrol that's
what MCC calls it when they go looking
for illegal fishermen it's called Patrol
not today necessarily go looking but
when when they kind of come in their
area they'll kind of go out to try to
stop them they take them the nets and so
when we do some of those things that
they're usually at night because that's
when the illegal fishermen are operating
and they'd operate without lights so you
go out there it's pitch-black and
Stephanie when we went out the first
time this
and encounter so then what happens is
they like kind of creep up on the
illegal fishermen and then they turn on
their lights and start shining lights on
them but then the fishermen have
brighter lights that they shine back on
you and they usually fish in groups and
so they'll what they do is they drop
their nets and they start and circling
you and there's lots of yelling and in
kamae which is the language of camera in
Cambodia and you know it's it's actually
really kind of scary it might not come
off that way on the video but in the
moment it's like anything can happen and
one one time when I was there the second
time we went out and we didn't have the
advantage it was like a new moon so
there was no light basically and you
could barely make out some shapes and
all of a sudden we realized that we were
pretty much surrounded by four or five
giant actually I think might have been
as much as seven giant moon Vietnamese
parrot rollers and you can hear on the
radio and then you know they started a
light start coming out when they see and
everybody knows who Paul is and what
they do so they're on the lookout for
Paul and and that's why they travel in
groups because then they can kind of
like combat them better so anyways at
that point it kind of surrounded us and
you know we actually kind of moved away
because we were worried about getting
you know too far away from they have a
medium sized boat a speedboat in a big
boat and if we were too far away from
reinforcements in the big boat then it
could be like an issue so we but nothing
ended up happening that night but it's
there's moments where yeah like when it
feels in control you know like it's it's
not as scary but the moment when you
feel like oh this has now gotten out of
control that's when you know your little
warning bells go off
having said that nothing's happened so
far and I think that you know legally
speaking like being getting in trouble
to government there is some risk there
in terms of they could just kind of
decide that they don't want to tolerate
us anymore and and not somebody I don't
think they would necessarily arrest us
but they could definitely kicks out of
the country and say we can't come back
and then we wouldn't be able to finish a
movie so there's a little bit of a fear
of that too which is you know I
think is a little unfair in a way just
not unfair but I think that you know we
are trying to do it with our movie
what's best for Cambodia you know
obviously as we see it but which is shed
light on this sort of issue because a
lot of these illegal fishermen are
really what they're doing is besides
just destroying the environment which is
Westerners does probably like what we're
initially drawn to but in terms of the
people in in the country you know
there's a lot of people who live off of
the ocean and subsistence fishing who
are having harder and harder time being
able to do that because the fish are
disappearing the habitat for the fish is
disappearing they'll put their crab pots
in or their own smaller Nets that just
get taken up by the big fishing boats
and they lose their livelihood and they
also get into skirmishes with these
larger illegal fishermen and so there is
people there who kind of need this to
happen for them not not nuts for the
movie but like the work that Paul and
Matt are doing and so getting that out
there to the larger audience thing is
going to be very helpful and you know I
would hope that the government would
understand that that's what we're trying
to do and we're not there to like make
them look bad but but to try to like you
know sort of correct some injustice is
perhaps yeah males here
you